As a very famous phrase in the legal
community,
hard cases make bad law and the
circumstances that apple and the FBI and
the Justice Department find themselves
in,
um,
certainly not by design,
it's a horrible tragedy that led to it,
but this is a wonderful example of a
very hard case you have without question
somebody who has done an evil,
evil,
murderous thing and they have used the
device that contains information that
might be not just marginally
extraordinarily useful to law
enforcement all over the world,
certainly to the United States in either
solving aspects of this crime or
preventing future atrocities from
occurring.
No question.
Apple says that it is not it.
This happens to be an apple device.
Apple has designed their devices so that
people can protect their information and
now a federal judge has ordered apple to
help crack the phone and gain access to
that information.
And apple in a,
in a very interesting letter from its
CEO,
Tim Cook has said,
well,
we don't,
we are rejecting the judge's order to
help crack this.
Why?
Because the problem that emerges is do
people have any expectation or
reasonable expectation of privacy when
they use technologies on networks by
exceeding to the judge's request and the
FBI has request a message would be sent
to people all over the world.
China,
Europe,
Latin America,
the US that if a rule of law,
if a judge,
Chinese judge Brazilian judge Russian
judge says that thing that you've
encrypted on your device,
we want access to it.
It would basically mean you have no
privacy.
If a rule of law,
and let's be very blunt here,
Chinese and Russian rule of law
standards are different than American or
British or German.
We will have lost standards.
Nobody could count on their devices to
protect them in any other circumstances.
To my mind that is the definition of a
hard case.
I am extraordinarily sympathetic to
apple.
I'm extraordinarily sympathetic to the
FBI and the Justice Department.
I'm even more sympathetic to the
families of the people who were hurt and
killed in in that,
in that attack,
that terrorist attack.
But the reality is this is one of those
circumstances where there is no good
answer and what ever answer is chosen is
the wrong one.